génial vous êtes avec moi sur ce plateau
bonjour merci Virginie d'être avec moi
va dire Poutine on le voit à organiser
cette visioconférence avec tous les
membres de son gouvernement le ministre
de de l'économie le Premier ministre
pour leur dire voilà qu'est-ce que vous
faites pour nous pour contrer cette
situation et puis aussi pour rassurer
les Russes oui surtout ce qu'on peut
retenir c'est que la formule de Vladimir
Poutine ce qu'il a dit c'est tous les
problèmes sont seront résolus la
population comprendra que la situation
et son contrôle c'est une un message
pour la population russe pour leur dire
oui les prix sont en train d'augmenter
oui vous voyez des MacDo qui se ferment
oui des boutiques étrangères aussi oui
effectivement les États-Unis vont
arrêter d'importer notre contrôle mais
l'économie va affecter mais on contrôle
tous et là réponse finalement à toutes
ces mesures oxydable à ces sanctions
occidentales ce qui est intéressant
aussi c'est que c'est une vision
conférence on a dit beaucoup depuis le
début que Vladimir Poutine est un homme
isolé et de plus en plus isolé ou même
vous avez été correspondante en Russie
donc vous l'avez certainement vu et
suivi mais là il est tout seul à son
bureau on se rappelle de cette image en
permanence quand il reçoit des autres
c'est que ce soit Emmanuel Macron ou
même son ministre des Affaires
étrangères c'est cette longue table
parce qu'il a peur aussi des maladies
enfin en tout cas ils se distance là
quand il fait une réunion avec les
ministres en charge de l'économie et
peut-être les secrétaire d'État c'est
par visioconférence il est tout seul il
est en train de prendre des notes donc
il y a une façon de se mettre en scène
de mettre en scène en tout cas le fait
que oui il est comment il est aux
commandes il est aux commandes mais il
est aux commandes seul et c'est ça qui
pose aussi un problème en ce moment aux
Occidentaux de se dire on ne sait pas
finalement jusqu'où il est prêt à aller
comment il fonctionne les experts les
gens qui sont qui suivent vraiment de
près ce qui se passe au Kremlin disent
que c'est un homme de plus en plus isolé
et que même ceux qui ont sa confiance
peut-être de moins en moins cette
ripossès
vous savez que juste après la
déclaration de guerre qui est une
déclaration de enfin c'était le 24
février quand il a déclaré l'opération
spéciale entre guillemets en Ukraine
ensuite il a reçu aussi un certain
nombre d'oligarques russes parce que
cette économie russe repose aussi sur le
soutien le soutien tacite ou même très
clair dans certains nombre d'oligarques
et eux aussi sont visés par les
sanctions économiques un certain nombre
de bien sont saisis des gènes sont des
pardon des des fonds des fonds sont
gelés d'avoir son gelées et
effectivement c'est le pari des
Occidentaux de se dire en touchant
l'économie russe la population mais
aussi les oligarques on va essayer de
faire en sorte que les taux se resserre
autour de Vladimir Poutine et que ça
provoque peut-être une réaction voilà
d'ailleurs en donnant la parole à son
premier ministre Mireille michoustine
qui annonce des mesures pour protéger
les petites et moyennes entreprises
c'est une façon de dire aux Russes voilà
la situation que vous le disiez tout à
l'heure et sous contrôle et donc on a
prévu tout un paquet de mesures on
maintient on maintient l'emploi on va
maintenir l'emploi ils ont dit que des
mesures en faveur de l'emploi vont être
maintenu parce que qu'est-ce qui va se
passer un certain nombre d'entreprises
occidentales ont annoncé leur départ on
se suspendu leurs activités d'autres ne
peuvent plus fonctionner parce que elles
n'ont plus accès aux liquidités à au
liquidités enfin au système bancaire
international donc l'activité économique
se réduit et donc certaines entreprises
ne peuvent plus travailler des
entreprises étrangères des entreprises
russes là le gouvernement russe Vladimir
Poutine on va intervenir c'est
l'interviewiste on va maintenir l'emploi
on va faire ce qu'il faut avoir de toute
façon maintenant vu la situation la
liberté de la presse la non liberté de
la presse en Russie impossible de
vérifier comment ces mesures vont être
véritablement entrer en application et
quel est le véritablement il va y avoir
un réel soutien à tous ces personnes qui
vont perdre leur emploi bien sûr merci
beaucoup Virginie Hertz pour pour